one of the areas that I work in is
security printing which is using labels
packaging and variable data printing and
so variable data printing is very
important it takes a lot of computer
science you if you look at a digital
press like the HP Indigo you'll see it
has a 12-pack of major processors on
board the reason for that is so that it
can provide a different set of data on
every single label or package that goes
out that's called variable data printing
or VDP and V DP is very important
because it allows you then to have a
unique ID or multiple IDs for each
package or label that goes out I brought
a couple of marks here this one actually
shows a small sheet of 16 different
you'll wonder what's different in each
of these I've got a different hidden
mark which is called a covert mark or
digital watermark hidden behind these
sort of solid tones in each of these
places more importantly one that you can
see are the overt that are actually
visible and those are these 2d barcodes
that are here along with the colors that
are around those each of those allow you
to have a barcode reader read the
barcode and plug you to a different
webpage if needed and the mark that's
around that actually allows you then to
legitimise it with a second stage the
power from this comes from the fact that
data has to stream out to these labels
at real time as they're printing and you
say well how much work can that be the
indigo actually prints things out at 812
pixels per inch you go why is it 812
Wells because it's 320 per centimeter so
it's tied to the metric system but if
you do a quick multiplication of that
and you recognize that there's a
different color for each of these pixels
there's as many as 800 by 800 which is
you can do the math is 640 thousand
pixels per square inch and I'm moving
this along at let's say for example 30
meters a minute that's a lot of data to
be printing out we need to be able to
program that so what we generally do is
try to get as much bang for the buck as
we can and only have the variable areas
be as small as necessary so I've got a
couple of other examples here that
really illustrate the gamut of
protection you can provide in this case
I've got five different little photos
each of which could have a unique covert
symbol associated with that one of
things that my colleagues have produced
is halftone steganography where we
actually have hidden information that's
tied into how we do our half toning
those work we're very well on spot
colors and so that might be what I've
shown here in the spot color area
there's also digital watermark providers
that are out there and they will provide
that in the image itself what I show in
this label here is the ability to have
really simple things that provide a lot
of variability we call this crazy text
and what it actually has is a wide
variety of features here is a very very
difficult to see but there's a light
gray turn arrow here there's this sort
of red warning sign and there's this
black square if I now come down to here
I have a red square a black smiley face
and a cyan ampersand let's suppose that
I just have 30 or 40 different of those
characters a smiley face an ampersand a
star etc and I have them in ten
different colors you can see very
quickly wait wait I've got 40 times ten
I have 400 different characters that I
can provide in any space I only need
three or four of those to have billions
of possibilities in terms of what I've
put in for the crazy text so if you add
that with what I've done with the color
tiles what I've done with the barcode
and then what I've done with some of the
other more covert features that are on
the packaging I very quickly have the
ability to roll out more different
packages than there are corpse in the
universe I'm assuming the HPL may only
people doing this sort of thing well the
money functions might be doing this sort
of thing no no so we actually have a
wide variety of partners that work on
this anybody who is a target for
counterfeiting or freely illicit economy
the illicit economy worldwide is 1.4
trillion dollars is the estimate by the
World Economic Forum's illicit economy
Council which I'm part of anybody who is
a target for counterfeiters is
interested in being able to provide
protection through variable data
printing on their packaging good targets
for that or anybody who has a luxury
good where they're actually charging you
more because you trust the brand a
luxury good provider then could
of for example a simple label there that
ties them into the back end a luxury
good manufacturer also has some
advantages because their supply chain
may be very limited in other words they
they only have a few stores in the world
that actually provide their products
think of like Gucci or somebody like
that and so they can actually directly
because the the the amount of profit
that they make per good is high enough
for them to individually labeled each of
those they might want a very strong
label out there that allows them to
authenticate it somebody else who wants
to do that is somebody who's
differentiating within a brand and that
might be for example somebody who is a
wine provider you know so if you've got
somebody at a winery most people
actually don't know much about wine and
they pick their wine off of the label
and so the label is both a
differentiator and in a way for them to
actually legitimize the wine ones one at
another you'd be surprised how much
counterfeiting is actually done in wine
pharmaceutical providers are one
seventy-five billion dollars of
estimated counterfeiting in
pharmaceuticals every year and they're
okay they want to spend a lot on the
label because it's a very high margin
item providing a very valuable service
for their end customers you could
actually say that they're responsible if
they don't do this because they do have
such a high margin and they are a good
target for counterfeit it's because of
the small size of production for those
playing devil's advocate here you should
are you sure this isn't just all about
just getting more money and I mean
what's the problem if if somebody kind
of you know put something different in a
box that looks a bit the same yeah
absolutely so aside from the primary
disruption of the brand which might be
something that HP would be more
concerned about you have then products
which are providing cancer protection
which are providing malarial protection
which are doing some kind of a
healthcare service you could also have
parts that are going onto airplanes or
cars you could also have people who
aren't just interested in making money
off the counterfeiting which is the
usual case most people who are doing the
counterfeiting are trying to be in this
for long term they pay their engineers
very well because they don't have to do
marketing or sales or any brand
development but what also happens is
this channels money into the hands of
few and if those few happen to be
state-sponsored terrorists you've got
yourself a legitimate concern that money
is being centralized into the hands of
people who want to use that money for
something much more dangerous than
just simply making money off of your
brand we like to say a big thank you to
audible.com for supporting the computer
file channel they're the leading
provider of audiobooks online they've
got over 250 thousand titles to choose
from so for your 30 day free trial go
over to audible.com slash computerphile
now I'd like to recommend a book by
Richard L Sanders today it's called the
phoenix conspiracy and it's one of a
series of books I got hooked on a couple
years back I'm up to about book 6 now
Richards imagined an amazing universe of
humans and aliens and a Galactic Empire
with kings and queens and all sorts of
really interesting ideas so check out a
Phoenix conspiracy sign up to your
30-day free trial at audible.com slash
computerphile thanks once again to
audible for supporting the computer file
channel I can tell but something's
change because I've got the original and
the new steganographic image with me but
if I just sent out an image of my dog
and I never sent out the original but
the camera took no one's going to know
that it's been imperceptibly changed
because they haven't got a reference